I just wanted to start with the
relationship that you guys have very
timeless many in real life he's really
fast she's paid pretty well to say that
yeah they've hit me a lot to really amp
you up Scott
nobody believes in you we know what I
can say is I don't know if I told you
this but so we had this scene the other
night where I introduced her to somebody
I'm like this is my daughter Nancy and
for some reason one take K Matt was like
this is my daughter Nancy I don't know
terrible choice but but saying this my
daughter Nancy I was saying someone felt
as natural as me saying like to you this
is my son Jackson who's like my real son
and so there's just there's a I don't
know you hope when you start something
like this that there is this kind of
source feeling and understanding and
sense of a relationship and I'm you know
felt that way with Kennedy from from
moment one yeah yeah absolutely
and Scott reminds me a lot of my real
dad so in Dave yeah I told you that yeah
yeah and he's terrible I'm gonna outrun
that they're both really awesome yeah
it's just something I think that's come
really natural to us it actually has
made it so going back to the fact that
our characters relationship is
tumultuous has actually become harder to
play for me because every time we argue
in a scene I just at the end want to be
like you're right down I love you I'm
sorry but it's but we can't we're not
there you know the characters aren't
there so yeah they certainly have a
tumultuous relationship essentially
after the death of Nancy's mother and
and Carson's wife they in order to
grieve sort of separated Nancy not by
choice really needed her dad in this
time and he chose to grieve in a
different way so because of that that
created a huge rift Nancy sort of feels
abandoned
and just totally loan in isn't going to
college because of this situation that
happened with her mother getting really
sick she just kind of hull her
applications sort of felt through and
she you know focused all her energy on
on her mom and and and fixing that
problem that she feels like she doesn't
have anything even her dad now and this
time that she really needs him yeah and
and and then you add to it you know
there's this kind of limbo where there's
the shift in dynamic because she's 18
now she's still living at home but she's
an adult who was expected to be off at
college already so so there's you add to
all of this emotional rift between us
where we've kind of grieved separately
and in very different ways and then you
add to it like well what am I even
allowed to ask of you or and or and III
would think through you know for Nancy
there's some sense of for me especially
it's like well what what what who do you
want me to be in your life now and so
you add all that on to this who they
haven't been able to be for each other
in a long time
and and and yeah there's just a lot of
tension and but but what I've loved is
is every time we're standing in a room
even though we're doing scenes where
we're playing out a story or two with
two people who just don't know how to
find each other underneath it you know I
think you feel everything they're trying
to find and and you know hopefully that
will be something that I always feel
like it's a really potent relationship
dynamic to put in the middle of a story
and then you know this sitting in the
middle of all these ghastly mysteries is
is pretty cool yeah
things which is pretty cool like I'm you
know women sexuality at that age yeah
really hasn't been explored so much on
network television can you talk a little
best and like for you
for me it's very exciting I think it's
very realistic and a really cool
exploration of watching somebody who's
extremely alone who's grieving who's
trying desperately to fill that void
with something and for her it's sort of
she's lived her life she's done I've
been perfect my whole life and look
where it got me
and now I'm just gonna do what I want
finally I'm gonna just let go of this
pressure to be somebody or um you know
be the perfect daughter the perfect
girlfriend or the perfect friend or
whatever and just sort of that release
from that that that permission to just
really do an experience what she wants
and follow her heart and and in that
does that lead her to some messy places
yeah
is that what real life is like yeah and
I am so glad that we're showing that
because I think it's extremely realistic
and it's really cool it's a really cool
yeah it's just a cool dynamic in it and
it interesting as you kind of explore
this relationship with with Nick and
Nancy is that it starts a very physical
thing from her perspective and and him
sort of being like hey I really like you
everything but then watching her allow
herself to to let those walls down in a
different way I think is so satisfying
because you know she's trying so hard to
hide herself and then bringing that into
like a sort of father/daughter
experience of what that's like and it
goes back to you know what is a father's
role yeah at that point past high school
18 I'm you know making money kind of
very independent and Nancy is always
like very independent self-sufficient
type of person um so yeah that I don't
know what do you yeah I mean at the end
of the last moment between them in
first episode in a pilot is him
basically not being able to contain the
sense that he has to say stay away from
that kid like so you you know he's now
talking to an adult who is living their
own life and but you know there's this
idea of like you're not a kid but you're
my kid and and that that kind of backs
its way even into the fundamental roots
of what this whole story is which is the
the crime solver because I think there's
this tension in that relationship
because I think they connect on that
level I think some of you know her sort
of inquisitive side probably came from
you know as an attorney as somebody
who's sort of digging into people's
lives and uncovering stuff but now you
know it's not a cute thirteen-year-old
kind of solving mysteries it's it's
somebody with real-world stakes here so
break it into stuff and years ago and
break was one thing
breaking into stuff now is a different
thing and I mean where can i and can't I
you know impose my my my will and desire
as a parent yeah and then there's a very
interesting aspect to is that he's
Nancy's lawyer too you know right that
gets very interesting yeah because it
becomes a relationship where he's
navigating your professional right you
know responsibility to be honest how
there's that familiar story but it's
technically like a reboot right no why
do you think people right now are so
involved and invested in like a rebooted
franchise hmm that's a really good
question I mean obviously you know
they're rebooting things that made a
impact on people and so I suppose I
don't know there's something and you
have a yeah I I think that I wasn't
going anywhere
I was looking at yeah I think that there
the world socially has changed so
extremely in very short amount of time
and I think it's exciting for people to
take older classic stories and see them
put in this new fresh exciting modern
world that we're in and see it in a way
that they can relate to now you know in
whether that's regarding diversity or
women's sexuality or like all just so
you know there's a million things but
having those lens that's brought two
classic stories I think is really cool
and exciting to people at least it is to
me and so I think that's probably that's
my explanation for it I guess the
excitement for a reboot sort of
situation and in this particular
situation obviously it's it's like it's
a reboot of a book series I suppose you
can frame it that way but the the
fundamental sense of mystery and fun and
characterization in those books I just
picked one up and I thought I was going
to read you know 20 pages and Jessica
okay that was nice to put a little
splash of the old book and like two
hours later I was almost done with it
and ready to read another one and so
they're they're I think they're doing a
really really brilliant job of being
inspired by the spirit of those books
but it's very much a today story yeah
but it's not a true reboot yeah it's
well they're doing like what would you
call like a reimagining no no that's
like it's actually it's the people who
created the original but it's but it's
it's based around like a Latino family
in there and their parents are deported
and so it's it's it's seem like you know
kids having to forge ahead without their
folks oh cool
kind of cool oh cool so you're into it
I'm excited to see it I hope it I'm
rooting for him